[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous devons nous avoir un
endroit un peu différent et je vais vous
expliquer quelque chose c'est en lien
avec ma chronique de cette semaine
et comme d'habitude je veux encore vous
parler de représentation de
représentativité dans les maisons dans
les médias sociaux mais dans un autre et
c'est beaucoup plus la grande semaine
pour moi par rapport à aussi comment on
déconstruit
qu'est ce que c'est la présence des
communautés autochtones dans les médias
alors pourquoi je dis ça c'est qu'il ya
une super bonne nouvelle c'est qu'elle
est apparue dans l'est notamment dans
mon fils de facebook mais aussi dans les
nouvelles de radio-canada c'est à propos
de la nes malik est une des jeunes
filles qui viennent la communauté et qui
a reçu une réponse positive avant son
inscription en médecine à l'université
laval
vous pouvez imaginer comment la
communauté est fier de nos jeunes qui
réussissent kiki qui vont de l'avant qui
dépasse certaines limites certain
plafond de verre aussi que nous ont un
peu court comment je vous resterai à
certains niveaux et dans l'entrevue est
bien amené sa force de son inspiration
qui était le dock installé vol en commun
est venu il a expliqué la médecine mais
aussi expliqué dans le point de vue
autochtone et commensal a expiré elle va
aller en médecine le processus pour se
rendre jusque là non seulement il y
avait cette nouvelle là mais il ya aussi
beaucoup d'autres vues et ça j'étais
très fier par rapport à mes liens du
fonds sont sa bande dessinée qui est
septembre c'est le québec qui est ni
dans mon pays d'une bande dessinée avec
beaucoup de témoignages de plusieurs
membres de communautés et qui montrent
différents aspects de témoignages ou au
vécu des communautés qui n'ont pas
nécessairement un fil conducteur unique
mais qui montre quand même la diversité
des manières de penser adversité les
manières de s'exprimer de voir
l'histoire aussi ils sont souvent
malheureusement ressemble des vite et
bien et donc nouvelle et même une
discussion du avec nasser qui était prêt
par contre je demande en vouloir parler
de cela
dans ma chronique c est le reportage
reportage sur les vaccins et les
cliniques de vaccination communauté
autochtone dans le reportage à voir une
image d'un membre de la communauté qui
se vaccinent pas partie de l'acte unique
de vaccination mais leurs voix un autre
reportage et elle se rend compte c'est
l'image la même image demande des
communautés mais on parle nulle part de
la clinique de vaccination quand on
parle juste de vaccination et ses autres
quand elle même a droit des faire son
idée de quand lille par nation peuvent
apparaît dans des reportages car l'image
des communautés d'accueil apparaît et
quand on peut on a nécessairement besoin
de savoir que c'est quelque chose de
tonnes par un viseur et hector nous
quelque chose
dalton par un visuel allochtone donc non
donné il va y avoir eu une espèce de
deux périodes vous l'imagerie qu'on
utilisait pour représenter des
reportages autochtone ou l'imagerie
concrets pour vulgariser ou généralisée
justement l'identité autochtone ne sera
plus nécessaire parce qu'on va avoir
appris à la communauté a repéré
justement la distinction à à prendre en
compte la distinction entre autochtones
et allochtones certains enjeux et on n'a
pas eu autant besoin de nécessairement
d'avoir des petits de l'eau pour qu'ils
disent c'est un sujet autochtone ce sens
n'est pas pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce
que jusqu'en je faisais les chroniques
par rapport à des pays en deux je me
suis fait dire mais pourquoi tu parles
de baby lieu de ça le rien à voir avec
la communauté autochtone et moi je dis
oui savoir communauté yagg com parce que
premièrement on écoute les polices
danoise depuis le même temps que le
reste de la communauté mondiale donc on
a un point commun dans ces histoires le
non seulement ça mais
les star wars sont beaucoup inspirés par
les cultures visuelles de kant et en
plus je pense à ma série demande dans
l'aérien il ya maintenant des
réalisateurs autochtone qui elles mêmes
des visuels et même des narratif
autochtone à travers justement la série
de starz
donc on va commencer à voir un mélange
mais une unicité dans nos récits commun
et ça ça va être difficile d'être
apprécié ces autochtones ça c'est
l'époque
pourquoi on ferait la distinction
aujourd'hui c'est parce que une grande
ignorance
il ya eu un grand effacement et on a
besoin de nommer les choses telles
qu'elles sont on a besoin de reconnaître
justement les distinctions mais pour que
jours c'est dire que ces distinctions la
font partie de l'éducation de tous les
membres de la société et elles sont
repérés l'allemagne
donc on est plutôt très visibles ont
fait partie de la communauté et c'est
pour ça que je dis comment je peux faire
quelque chose qui a pas l'air du tout
mais qui pour moi est autochtone visite
bicycle sapin mon vélo je suis le
capitaine pour moi mais est ce que pour
vous ce serait peut-être pas donc pour
cette semaine je vous invite à justement
penser aux billets que vous avez pensé
aux distinctions vous faites dans les
visuels
parce que ça peut amener des fois une
exclusion des communautés ça peut même
amener une mésinterprétation des
communautés je donne aux élections qu'on
habitait sur la rive-sud personnes
parler des communautés autochtones est
souvent ma mère se faisait identifiés
pour quelqu'un d'une communauté
asiatique mon frère une communauté sud
américain mais jamais en sentant
personne n'aurait pas aussi à désigner
et c'est ça qui était fantastique dans
le titre du livre de c'est le québec qui
est né dans mon pays je vous invite
vraiment aller découvrir ce sport là ça
allait revenir avec ça et bien c'est de
trois appareils
exister sans nécessairement a besoin de
le crier sur tous les toits
et bien sûr je vous ai laissé un petit
indice aujourd'hui sur qu'est ce que tu
pourrais visuellement rendre ma
chronique et plus hautes écoles
je vous le point très fort mais je peux
m'asseoir vous allez trouver alors que
je vous souhaite une belle semaine je
vous invite à justement ouvrir les yeux
par rapport à vos biens et à l'aider
construire parce que c'est ce qui va
créer le nouveau dont on passe une bonne
semaine